foreign
is in Lima Ohio hi Dan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
thanks Dave for taking my call sure
what's up appreciate it well I recently
um had knee surgery both both Total
knees so and as I'm going to physical
therapy and I have December 2nd as I'm
going to physical therapy they're
telling me I can no longer kneel and I
can no longer climb and I am a carpenter
and that's what I do so it's like okay I
have to do something different
um I do have options I can go ahead and
retire I have to take a penalty and I
would draw approximately Thirty one
hundred and eighteen dollars a month
until the day I die
so that's not a bad option but it's like
I want to make sure I do the right
option if I make it until 62 I grew
almost 3 800 a month how old are you
I'll be 58 in January
yeah a union carpenter I take it
yes new Carpenter yes okay
so the rent Rave about uh college and
everything else like that for you people
that ain't smart
the union trade is a great thing
pipefitter boiling anchor Carpenter it's
all great thing yeah what do you what do
you make a year back when you were
still uh swinging a hammer
I make about 65 a year 60. good for you
you know how much overtime I work which
is a little energy a lot
do you have any other savings
yes we I also had it the carpenter Union
comes with also an annuity and I've got
like 34 000 in that and I've pulled that
out of the carpenters union and put it
in Edward Jones in stocks
but you know as you can see the last
year the stock market has not been
friendly cheaply
to my uh Investments there so um I would
I would like to know more about
switching it to a a mutual fund of some
sort but you know we'll
do decent through my year like this year
um well I mean you would be selling
something that's down and buying
something that's down so it's as good a
time to do it as any
as far as that switching that over goes
okay so you're you're not going to be a
carpenter anymore and
um you're gonna be making Thirty One
hundred dollars right
right so what are you gonna do now
well
and that's the thing I could go do
something else for a couple years and
I'd like to because I would like to pay
off my mortgage
I mean you're young you got a lot of
things you could do you just not be a
carpenter you're gonna be something else
and this is what we call an encore
career it's the second act
yes yeah I mean you're 58 you still have
lots of time even even just in general I
think we had this conversation a few
weeks ago where it's nice to keep your
brain active and moving and doing things
even if it's not the career you've known
for so many years just to have that
stimulation versus I bet you all know
super super cold days or the super super
hot days you had something pop into your
head you'd like to do someday
you know I messed my shoulder I got
another story I messed my shoulder up in
13. so I am
went back got six or if my rotator
dropped my library I took off my biceps
so I get it fixed I go back to work a
year later same pains you know so this
is a doctor doctor says you need to do
something different your Carpenter is
tearing your shoulder up so I started my
own business I started a Matco tool
franchise and I did that for like five
years and I had a son-in-law that moved
back from Florida and I was like I was
like come on with me give this a try and
he did awesome at it so I set him up in
that business and I went back being a
carpenter so and then recently my knees
you know I knew they were bad you know
and then you go get them so if you can
do a Mac Tool business you can do
another business right
yeah but I'm telling you those days that
you were laid up in the hospital or
those days it was too hot to be outside
or too cold to be outside and you were
out there anyway you were thinking
Someday I'm gonna go do blank blank
blank blank blank and you ought to go do
that now
that's all I'm saying you're gonna
you're not a carpenter anymore your dog
told you you're done do you think you
should go ahead and take the early
penalty and get the 31 18 or wait on
that like do another career that finally
funds his life I mean yeah if you can
just eat if you can make enough to live
and not take it now and take it at 65
that's fine uh that's going to be a lot
better deal for him
um but or take it now and still go get
money right anyone's okay yeah if you if
you do take it now it you could still
get a job that's a little bit more of a
passion project like if you want to go
you know volunteer not volunteer but
work in a non-profit or something like
that I guess that's the case now I want
to go make some money so get a real like
yeah he ran a business making money with
tool business before so best case
scenario he waits till 62. don't touch
that and then let it get to where it's 3
800. either one's fine but if he takes
it now it does take the pressure off
trying to make the other thing happen
immediately because you got money to eat
with yeah so I'm probably going to take
it now just for that reason but I'm
still gonna say and go start another
thing man yeah you've done it before
they're going to kick your feet up on on
three thousand bucks a month you're not
done at that so you need some more than
that well and even just beyond the money
you talk you told the story recently
about your fishing friend who took off
for a while then he got fat and then
went back to work yeah and he didn't
enjoy it a lot of people you know they
get all that time back and then they're
like wait a minute I want to do
something I'm excited to do something I
want to get out of the house
that's exactly right so there's there's
a benefit of that and I I just think
you know um
all I'm saying is you you've been
through all this pain physically
and and now you don't really have the
option of doing this anymore so the only
question is whether you take the
retirement now or you wait and take it
later doesn't really matter either one's
gonna be fine but neither case is enough
so you're going to be create you need to
go create some income doing something
else that's the important part of this
particular
discussion by the way folks it is good
to stop and recognize this okay
Buford did a book called half time
and he said that uh men in particular
the data tells us
spend the first half of their life in
acquisition in the second half of their
life seeking significance women too but
he had the study he did was on men and
the research that he had was on that and
if you don't reach for significance in
that second half you tend to get off the
rails and um you know get into drugs or
you know run off with secretary in a red
convertible or whatever that kind of
stuff right so you so guys you got to
need to aim at something in the second
half now sometimes your second half
starts at 30. sometimes it starts at 58.
you know what's your second half it does
it's not an age thing it was there's a
like an arc to your career an arc to
what you're doing in the first half of
it is acquisition the second half of
significance
the important part of that conversation
is the other piece of data that's out
there that we do know is that your
highest the typical person your highest
income potential decade is the decade of
your 50s
50 to 60. because that's the point in
your life that all of your experience in
your career field
is now valuable
and before then you've been Gathering
that experience by making mistakes now
all of those mistakes are called
experience and and you you really know
things that you just didn't know before
they put you in a sweet spot to go
really cha-ching and and so that's why
this Encore career thing comes up is
very very very important